senator sheldon whitehouse gets caught
with his hand in the racist cookie jar
but faces no consequences
democrats begin to walk back their
radical voting proposals and new york
city votes for mayor i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you
gotten a vpn yet is it expressivevpn.com
ben speaking of which the last thing you
want is somebody peeking over your
shoulder when you're
on the internet particularly not the big
tech companies many of whom are going to
take all of your data and then repackage
it and then sell it to people you don't
even
know we all take little risks every day
when we go online whether we think about
it or not
we think our connection probably won't
be interrupted by hackers or our data
probably won't be used against us but
using the internet without expressvpn
it's like driving without car insurance
why would you take that risk when you
don't have to
every time you connect to an unencrypted
network cafe hotel airport
any hacker on the same network can gain
access to your personal data whether
it's your passwords
financial details etc it doesn't take
much technical knowledge to hack
somebody just some cheap hardware and
your data is valuable
hackers can make up to a thousand bucks
per person selling personal information
on the dark web expressvpn acts as
online insurance it creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so hackers can't steal
your personal data it would take a
hacker with a supercomputer over a
billion years to get past
express vpn's encryption that's how good
they are and it's super easy to use you
can install with one click and then
with just another click it is now active
secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com that's expr
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
get an extra three months for free
expressvpn.com
ben to get started alrighty so
there is a simple truth when it comes to
today's racial debate
and that simple truth is that if you are
on the side of the angels you can do or
say whatever you want you can be as
racist as you could possibly want to be
and you will survive
but if you hold the wrong positions you
don't have to be racist in order for you
to be clocked about the ears and if we
don't know
if we're just not sure where you are
then we'll cuddle you about the ears
until you declare
that you are on the side of the angels
that is the way that this particular
debate works
if you are not on the side of the woke
well
you don't have to be racist in order for
them to declare you racist and just go
after you
if you're in the middle you're kind of
neutral nobody said anything and then
evidence comes out that you may in fact
not even be racist but like have been
associated once with some people
who may once have been racist then we'll
just cuddle you until you come out in
favor of the woke
and if you're woke you're good if you're
woke you're totally good and this
is all within the logic of wokeness
of critical race theory and identity
politics it is all within that logic
because that logic suggests that
individual racism is not the problem
systemic racism is the problem systemic
racism
is simply defined as any system of power
anywhere that results in inequality of
outcome as we've discussed at length on
the show
well what that means according to the
proponents of vocaism and identity
politics
is that if you wish to tear down those
systems if you're complicit in tearing
down the systems if you do
what we want then we will ignore your
personal
racism because personal racism is really
just ancillary it's something that you
can use as a cudgel to hit people with
but if that person is helping you
already why would you care which is why
ralph northam
the governor of virginia who was caught
being in like his medical
yearbook in the 1980s either wearing a
kkk outfit or blackface right those were
the two choices
there was no third choice where he
wasn't photo the two choices were
blackface or kkk outfit
that guy who democrats at the time said
you know what maybe we should get rid of
him
maybe he should go you know it's kind of
bad right and then he didn't go anywhere
now you have joe biden basically
campaigning with the guy you have
democrats like terry mcauliffe talking
up
ralph northam because if you
the the rule typically in in democratic
circles
is not you either die a hero or you live
long enough to become a villain
it's either you die villain or you stick
around long enough to become a hero
whether we're talking about katie hill
or they're talking about al franken or
whether they're talking about
ralph northam if you are a democrat and
you are useless to them
at a particular time and you're ousted
or you're yelled at and then later you
become useful we will rehabilitate you
okay so the person who articulates this
i think quite beautifully
is of course nicole hannah jones and
nicole hannah jones who is the de facto
editor of the new york times a
professional liar
uh a pulitzer prize-winning liar
actually considering the 1619 project
is a false recapitulation of the
nation's history
from a racist perspective here's what
nicole hannah jones explaining
and when it comes to critical race
theory when it comes to the teaching of
history when it comes to all this stuff
individual racism no longer matters the
only thing that matters
is where you stand with regards to the
structures of power
which of course nicole and jones it's
amazing the structures of power never
include
the places where the left is in control
so they will say oh the structures of
power they're really bad this is the
hierarchies in america they're just
terrible
but everything's great at the new york
times except for
you know every so often they have to
fire like james bennett or a barry weiss
or something
but if you're nicole hannah jones we
never talk about the amount of power you
wield in society
we never talk about the amount of power
wielded by the woken society
we're talking about the other structures
of power here's nicole hannah jones
both my work and critical race theory
are about
structures they're not about individuals
and they're actually trying to move us
away from thinking that individuals
alone are responsible
you know a few bad apples are
responsible for inequality and are
responsible for discrimination
and trying to show that there's actually
much larger structures at play here
and that's really what they're trying to
do they don't want an examination
of the systems of power they don't want
an examination of the larger structures
that we started to see
coming out of the global protest
movements last year they want to pretend
that the inequality we see is just a
matter of a few bad actors and so
they're trying to suppress these truths
okay so this works a couple of ways one
it is untrue that the systems of power
in the united states are geared toward
harming black people that is simply not
true
in the united states it was true in 1960
it is certainly not true
in 2021 in fact if you're going to look
at the systems of power in the united
states
they're tremendously geared towards
specific affirmative action programs
that largely benefit black people
at the expense in many cases of asian
people if you look at all of the
affirmative action programs that are
used at university levels they are not
directed
toward helping all people of color
they're aimed at helping particular
people of particular colors okay so we
can talk about the structures of power
but it works both ways
individual racism will be overlooked if
it helps to destroy
these structures of supposed power
perfect example
case in point today sheldon whitehouse
okay so
sheldon whitehouse is a really terrible
senator
from delaware and according to the new
york post senator sheldon whitehouse is
facing new scrutiny
over his decades-long membership in an
allegedly all-white private beach club
as he builds himself as a progressive
and prominent critic of systemic racism
dismissing membership based on race as a
long tradition in rhode island
the controversy began when white house
was confronted friday by a go local
providence reporter who published the
video
along with an article on saturday
detailing what occurred after asking
about the senator's membership at the
newport-based
bailey's beach club part of the spouting
rock beach association
the progressive politician answered this
way here is how he answered when he was
asked about his membership at bailey's
by the way for like several years people
have been asking about his membership at
this particular
beach club which apparently has no black
members
are there any minority members of the
club now i think the
people who are running the place are
still working on that i'm sorry it
hasn't happened yet um do you have
concerns in 2021 i mean obviously it's
been four years you had remarks on the
floor
following the deaths of brianna taylor
and george floyd saying
you know hoping to root out systemic
racism in the country
um your thoughts on an elite all-white
wealthy club again in this day and age
um
you know should these clubs continue to
exist
it's a long tradition in rhode island
and there are many of them
and i think we just need to work our way
through the issues okay now
here's the amazing thing my
understanding is that it is illegal to
have all white clubs in the united
states right the civil rights act of
1964 bars
discrimination in public and private any
sort of public accommodation
is barred from single race membership
so i am unaware whether this beach club
i mean i've not seen any reports on this
i don't think
from my understanding that this beach
club overtly has a rule that says no
black members
in fact i think in the past they have
had black members so the normal answer
that sheldon whitehouse would provide
here is
we have membership criteria we evaluate
the membership criteria based on
merit and sometimes there are people who
are black and sometimes there are people
who are not black but the problem is
because sheldon whitehouse has fallen
into the woke crap of believing
that equal outcome is the guarantor of
equity of fairness
because he believes that he now has to
answer for the fact that there are no
black members of this particular club
and there haven't been
for quite a while in fact when he was
first elected in 2006
he disavowed his membership and pledged
to quit the club currently his wife
sandra
is one of the three largest shareholders
in the club
reach for comment by the washington post
white house senior spokesperson
megan mccabe said the country club was
not all white but declined to provide
further information or proof
mccabe said the club has no such
restrictive policy the club has had and
has members of color
the senator has dedicated his entire
career to promoting equity and
protecting civil rights as his record
shows
efforts to reach management at bailey's
by phone were unsuccessful the
individual who answered refused to
transfer the call and said
the club was declining to comment the
local had pressed white house according
to the new york post and his office over
his membership multiple times in 2017
noting that more than a decade had
passed since his unkept campaign promise
was made
after the lawmaker repeatedly declined
requests for comment that's when you saw
that particular video okay and uh the
left-wing senator told the outlet i
think it'd be nice if they changed a
little bit but it's not my position
and asked if he intended to pressure the
club to do better on diversity white
house said i will take that up privately
before declining to comment on the
matter further
okay so let's say that this were a
republican
or just a second do you think that this
answer would prove sufficient to the
media
there's been like a 24-hour news cycle
and that's pretty much it by the end of
the week nobody will be asking sheldon
whitehouse about this there will be no
calls for him to resign
there will be no calls for him to issue
any sort of shame-faced apology
all he has to do is basically just wait
it out and sheldon whitehouse knows this
because
he is in the good graces of the people
who believe that the only true racism is
opposing their agenda
and now again here's the reality do i
think that sheldon whitehouse is racist
against black people in any traditional
sense i have no evidence that he is
do i even think that this club is racist
against black people i have no evidence
that it is again it does not have a
specific policy
that bars black people as far as i'm
aware because that would be federally
and state illegal
but sheldon whitehouse can't give that
answer because again sheldon
whitehouse's entire perspective is
rooted in the idea that if there is any
group
that does not include a proper
percentage of people
by the general population statistics
then it must
inevitably be inequitable and here's the
thing so long as he holds that position
in public he doesn't actually have to
hold that position in private
this is the beautiful thing about being
properly woke
you can say the right things publicly
and if privately
you live by the same rules as everybody
else namely you belong to a beach club
and the beach club has membership
requirements and sometimes there are
black people who meet that and sometimes
they're black people who don't meet that
same thing with universities you send
your kid to a private school and that
private school does not admit
people based solely on the basis of race
and and maybe the racial constituency of
that private school is not adjudicated
on the pace of ethnicity
it's instead adjudicated on the basis of
entrance exams or on the basis
of past academic experience one place of
community membership
you can do all of those things so long
as you are properly woke this is the
beauty of the systemic racism argument
you never
ever have to be held accountable for
living
your politics personally right when it
comes to the right the personal is
political
right so if you're somebody on the right
you send your kid to a private school
then we rip you up and down but if
you're on the left
and you're against school vouchers you
can send your kids to a private school
and no one's going to say boo
if you're on the left and you say all
the proper words about equity
you can belong to an all-white beach
club and nobody is going to say boo
beyond about 15
hours of controversy and then we'll all
just move on because we all know the
real thing that's important here and
that is fighting the systems of power
fighting the systems of power only the
systems of power the left says you
should fight
alrighty in just a second we're going to
see that this sort of push
from the left is having some rather
deleterious consequences
on their own perspective when it comes
to to winning elections we'll get to
that in just one second first
when you're running a business hr issues
can absolutely kill you wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations
and hr manager salaries aren't cheap
they're an average of 70 000 bucks a
year
bambi is spelled b-a-m-d-e-e it was
created specifically for small business
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr policy maintain your compliance
all for just 99 bucks a month with bambi
you can change hr from your biggest
liability to your biggest strength your
dedicated hr manager is available by
phone
email or real-time chat from onboarding
determinations they customize your
policies to fit your business
and help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
their month-to-month there are no hidden
fees you can cancel any time you didn't
start your business because you wanted
to spend time on hr compliance
let bambi help get your free hr audit
today when you start a business very few
people
think about hr and then later it very
often comes back to bite them directly
on the tokens
instead why not get everything in order
right now by heading on over to
bambi.com
shapiro again that's bambi.com shapiro's
schedule your free hr audit today
that is bambi.com shapiro b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash shapiro today alrighty so
meanwhile democrats once again are
realizing that their agenda is not what
the american people want see the thing
is that joe biden was elected
on the basis that he would be not donald
trump right that he would basically
restore a sense of
calmness and and solidity and and
absolute placidity to american politics
that american politics would return to a
new normal where the professionals
were in charge and we wouldn't have
these sort of radical shifts in the
winds each and every day no tweeting
from the toilet and all of that
so joe biden has kept the face of
placidity and stalinity because he's not
alive
but the actual policy being pursued by
the democrats is anything but placid
see this was the great weirdness of the
trump administration every day was a new
news cycle about whatever the man
decided to tweet but the actual stuff
that the administration was doing was
fairly traditional
lowering taxes strengthening the
military allowing for people to practice
their
religion in three ways like these were
fairly traditional american things
under the last administration the major
policy shift
over the last 20 years have all been
democrat policy shifts that's when
barack obama attempting to
revise the entire nature of the bargain
between the individual citizen and the
government by forcing you to buy health
insurance or fining you
right it was joe biden who is now
attempting to suggest
basically universal basic income in
other guys and make
millions of people more dependent on the
government i mean
it is democrats who've been making all
these radical policy changes it is not
republicans who've been making radical
policy changes
okay so joe biden's not being alive has
helped shield
democrats from the impact of this but
not completely because it turns out that
every so often americans get a glimpse
behind the veil
of joe biden's unaliveness and they
suddenly see what democrats are pushing
and they don't like it very much a
perfect case in point
is democrats walking back their
opposition on voter id
and you can tell how how bad this is for
democrats
by the way the washington post phrases
this so aaron blake is the senior
reporter at the washington post covering
this you ready
stacy abrams and the democrats evolution
on voter id oh it's an evolution is it
it's not a complete reversal it's not
that they all said that voter id
was a grave injustice barring black
people from the polls
and they've been saying this for years
no you're not having
long-term or short-term memory loss when
you when you seem to remember democrats
saying that voter id was the new jim
crow
that's because they said it but now
they've just evolved you see
they've evolved in a more right-wing
direction is that what happened
so for example raphael warnock in
georgia he understands that he's about
to get tossed out on his ear
because remember he took over an
uncompleted term
so raphael warnock is up for re-election
as in next year
okay and because rafael warnock is up
for re-election in 2022
he is i think running scared and he
should be running scared because he's
likely to lose that seat
that seat is very tenuous i know right
now you have a quick political report
that has a leaning d
i do not think that is a lean dc i think
that is lena rc i think warnock is in
serious trouble
he got in basically because of the fluke
of donald trump intervening in the
georgia senate elections last time
around
otherwise he definitely would not be in
the senate right now
okay but put that aside raphael warnock
was campaigning pretty openly for a long
time about how things like voter id were
racist
because rafael warnock is a radical so
here was warnock just a few months ago
comparing georgia's voting law which
included voter id to jim crow
it all began right here in georgia
with these unnecessary and unjustifiable
voter id laws
there are some who say well we are
concerned about voter fraud
we're worried that people might without
these state ids which constitute
in my estimation a poll tax
that they might vote twice
are you kidding it's hard enough to get
people to vote once
meanwhile stacey abrams do the exact
same thing the the
it is incredible to me and stacy abrams
is still brought forth
by the media as the representative of
true
honest american voting when she has
claimed four years without any evidence
that voter suppression led to her defeat
in her georgia gubernatorial race she
was literally honored by the democrats
at the last democratic national
convention
in the governor's room they had like a
governor's chat room
and stacey abrams was included as though
she'd been elected governor and then
they all have the temerity to say how
dare donald trump
not concede an election stacey abrams as
far as i'm aware
still has not conceded really the
georgia election she still says that she
was only not elected because of voter
suppression for which she has provided
zero evidence okay and then after
georgia decided they were going to pass
this law that shored up some of their
voting procedures she over and over and
over again
suggested that voter id was bad that
this new georgia law was like jim crow
she openly suggested in a usa today
editorial
that she understood why people would
boycott the state of georgia
over that georgia voting law and then
when it turned out that
her intervention her radical
intervention was likely to lose georgia
both of its democratic senators then she
started to walk that back and she
actually
had usa today retconned her story they
actually went in
and removed the section it's amazing
that they were i mean honestly like
that any outlet would do this is kind of
incredible they
took that part of her editorial and just
removed it where she
quasi endorsed boycotting the state here
is stacey abrams not all that long ago
suggesting that voter id was a very bad
thing
we have a right to vote in the united
states that is
afforded to eligible american citizens
but we have seen over the last
20 years a constriction on who has the
right
to use that right we have seen it
through voter id laws
you can't get on the rolls and if you
get on the rolls you can't stay
you may not be able to cast your ballot
because they close your precinct or they
change the rules
that's rigging the game voter id is
rigging the game
i mean she said it right okay so now the
democrats looked at the polls it turns
out that every single subsection of the
american population
is fine with voter id which makes
perfect sense because we all show id for
everything in this country
and when you fly on a plane you have to
show id when you buy alcohol
you have to show id when you're driving
you have to be carrying id
no one has a problem with this except
for idiot democrats who apparently
believe that it's a form of voter
suppression to ask people to show that
they are who they say they are when they
vote
no one has a problem with this now black
americans not white americans not
hispanic americans
nobody okay except for radical democrats
like stacey abrams well now it turns out
that their push for this is backfiring
because no one is on their side
so now shockingly they've reversed their
position on all of this
right it was systemic racism a moment
ago but then it turned out
that it was unpopular and so now it's
not systemic racism anymore
well here is aaron blake explaining the
evolution quote it still isn't clear
exactly what will happen with senator
joe manchin the third middle ground
proposal on voting rights
senate majority leader charles schumer
is planning to bring up the for the
people act which joe manchin opposes in
its current form for a vote on tuesday
while saying he will work with manchin
but that's just about getting to all 50
democratic votes getting to the
necessary 60 still looks prohibited
based on early gop reviews of even
mansion's friendlier proposal
but regardless of what happens with the
bill manchin's proposal has moved the
needle in one significant way
signaling a softening by key democrats
on voter id among the carrots for
republicans in manchin's proposal is a
voter id provision
republicans have pushed voter id hard at
the state level in recent years but
rather than merely describe mansion's
voter id proposal as a concession
some key democrats have suggested they
don't really object to it or the broader
concept
at all forbes georgia gubernatorial
candidate stacey abrams
was asked last week on cnn whether she
could accept this compromise what joe
manchin laid out even if voter id was
part of it
and abram said quote that's one of the
fallacies of republican talking points
that have been deeply disturbing
no one has ever objected to having to
prove who you are to vote
it's been part of our history since the
inception of voting
um i just played you a clip of stacy
abrams
saying that voter id was a form of voter
suppression
you're not crazy she's lying okay same
thing with raphael warnock he said quote
i have never been opposed to voter id
i don't know anybody who believes that
people shouldn't have to prove they are
who they say they are
um nope nope
warnock said in 2015 voters without a
driver's license or state id must
surrender their personal information and
risk identity theft just to receive an
absentee ballot
dealing with these voter id laws this is
not about voter verification
this is about voter suppression oh
really oh really so here's the bottom
line
every argument is directed toward power
of course
it is not directed toward honesty these
people didn't actually believe that
voter id was a form of voter suppression
they just believed that if they said it
over and over and over again they could
get a bunch of voters
progressive white voters in the suburbs
and black voters presumably to vote
democrat
if you just called things jim crow over
and over maybe people will think that
your opponent is jim crow
this is the way that democrats attempt
to win arguments now
they're not attempting to actually push
forward the power and and
positivity of their agenda instead it's
all about if you oppose me
it's because you're in favor of systemic
racism it truly is an amazing amazing
thing
and this is why you're seeing them tried
out barack obama to make the same
arguments now that's why they keep
bringing up the specter of trump we'll
get to all that
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that you need a good
night's sleep everybody needs a good
night's sleep and let me tell you about
the best pillow on the market you know
what i'm going to say
my pillow my pillow has a passion to
help everyone get the best sleep of your
life
my pillow didn't stop by simply creating
the best pillow though my pillow created
the new giza dream bed sheets they look
and feel great that means an even better
night's sleep for me that is crucial for
a busy schedule
my pillow has the world's best cotton
giza cotton it is ultra soft and
breathable extremely durable my pillow
sheets come with a 60 day money back
guarantee and a 10 year warranty it's a
long warranty for sheets my goodness the
first night you sleep on the giza sheets
you will never want to sleep on anything
else giza dream sheets come in a variety
of sizes and colors
and my pillow is making a special offer
right now for my listeners you'll
receive two for one
low price plus free shipping and i have
all the my pillow products
like all over my house they are
tremendous everything they say they are
they really
are go to mypillow.com click on that
radio listener square use promo code
dailywire there you will find not only
this amazing offer but also
deep discounts on all my pillow products
including the my pillow mattress topper
my pillow towel sets and so much more
call 1-800-951-7163
use the promo code at daily wire go to
mypillow.com make sure you use that
promo code
dailywire go check them out right now
okay so if the democrats agenda seems to
be falling off in popularity and they've
got a real problem here
because the democrats have basically hit
high watermark i don't think they're
passing any more
serious legislation aside from some sort
of budget through reconciliation here
kristen cinema and joe manchin because
they are
democrats in purple to very very red
states in manchin's case
they're not going gonna kill the
filibuster kristen cinema has a piece in
the washington post today saying as much
she says we have more to lose than gain
by ending the filibuster
she says everyday arizonans are focused
on questions that matter most in their
daily lives
is my job secure can i expand my
business can we afford college what
about health care when can i retire is
my community safe
meanwhile much of washington's focus is
on a senate rule requiring 60 votes to
advance most legislation
arizonans expect me to do what i
promised when i ran for the house and
senate to be independent like arizona
and work with anyone to achieve lasting
results
lasting results rather than temporary
victories just destined to be reversed
undermining the certainty that america's
families and employers depend on
the best way to achieve durable lasting
results is bipartisan cooperation
i understand bipartisanship says
christian cinema seems outdated to many
pundits but the difficult work of
collaboration is what we expect in
arizona and i still believe it is the
best way to identify realistic solutions
instead of escalating all or nothing
political battles that result in no
action
or in whipsawing federal policy
reversals i mean by the way the fact
that it is now considered controversial
to hold the position that the filibuster
should remain
is pretty incredible i see a lot of
democrats like well mitch mcconnell were
in charge he'd get ri
democrats say this kind of stupid crap
without realizing mitch mcconnell was in
charge with a republican house with a
republican president and didn't kill the
filibuster
it is only democratic leadership now
that is pretty openly calling for
killing the filibuster
but the reality is this agenda is going
nowhere so
that means that democrats are sort of
left with nothing to campaign on
remember they control all branches of
government
at this point and the only thing that
they've done is pass a giant spending
bill
that's it and propose a radical shift in
the nature
of american voting which is not going to
get passed
so instead what they're going to do is
they're going to just keep up the banter
right they're just going to keep up the
push
that if you oppose their agenda it's
because you're a racist so here's barack
obama pushing
h.r 1 which is an absurd piece of
legislation and of course trying to link
it to trump
this is they need trump so bad i mean
they cannot see straight how bad they
need trump
every host on cnn leads their show every
night with trump trump has been out of
office since january last i checked it
is now june
he's been out of office a full six
months and yet
the democrats can't let go of the thing
they can't let go of it
and the reason that they can't let go of
it is because trump was the font head of
all evil and
because trump was so likely to jump into
these pitched kind of political battles
with them
they loved being able to push up against
trump you think joe biden wins 80
million votes if he's running against
anybody but trump of course not
right democrats are like teenagers who
require a parent
to take a hard position so they can yell
at their parents okay so
here's barack obama yelling at trump
trump's not in office
trump is not at the forefront of the
political scene trump's not on twitter
he's not on facebook he's sending out
missives every day
but the only people who seem paying
attention to those missives in mass
numbers
are democrats and members of the media
which by the way is why there was a
straw poll the other day suggesting that
ron desantis might outpull donald trump
now
that's without donald trump attacking
desantis of course trump does have the
unique
superpower of being able to destroy
anything in his path i'm not sure that
he's able to build
as well as he destroys but in any case
democrats require trump they require him
as a foil in order for them to push past
their radical agency here's barack obama
trying this routine
we can't wait until the next election
because if we have
the same kinds of shenanigans that
um brought about january 6th
and you know if we have that
for a couple more election cycles we're
going to have real problems in terms of
our democracy long term we are not going
to have
any ability to preserve democracy long
term are you kidding me
so he wants to federalize all federal
procedure like all state voting
procedure he wants to take that up to
the federal level
he wants to enshrine ballot harvesting
he wants to enshrine no voter id right
he wants the more radical version of hr1
not even the mansion
senate one which is not a good bill but
at least not as bad as hr one
and he wants to do all of that in the
name of january 6th which
literally was a security failure okay
let's let's chalk up january 6
what it actually was in reality okay
january 6th
in the end was about the failure of the
government to stop people from invading
the federal building
that's it okay that that's not to
minimize
donald trump's bad rhetoric between
november 6th and january 6th or
november 4th and january 6th that is not
to minimize the foolishness
stupidity and malice of people who
decided to invade the capitol building
seeking to do harm to others
but in the end when faced with a mob
intends on doing bad things around a
pretty
predictably targeted building the real
failure there was a security failure
which is what a bipartisan senate
committee already found right okay but
but to treat that as some sort of
assault on the democracy itself meaning
that democracy itself was not going to
work anymore unless you do what barack
obama wants you to do
namely loosen voting procedures to the
point where voter fraud becomes
extremely possible
to to foster a voting system that has
less verifiability
that's that's a pretty that's a pretty
long pot if a tumor is doing the same
thing right so schumer is also saying
that that trump is is still these voting
laws in the states you know the ones
that are kind of popular
those are all trumps doing they need
trump so bad
they need him so bad they can't honestly
it's amazing the obsession they have
with trump is unreal
donald trump lied over and over and over
again
poisoning our democracy lighting a fire
beneath republican state legislatures
who immediately launched the most
sweeping voter suppression effort in at
least 80 years
just a note how despicable a man is
donald trump
okay again the most the most uh
voter support 80 years the most
despicable voter suppression in 80
like you you realize that you go 80
years backwards from here you're talking
about the 1940s right
so he's talking about like comparing
these laws about voter id which are
widely popular
to jim crow again and it's all cause
it's trump because trump's a jim crow
figure
if the democrats don't have much but
they'll but they need trump to kick
around
they're just gonna get clobbered in 2022
and they deserve to get clobbered in
2022 if they continue to push this
partisan agenda
and then to defend their own worst
players like the sheldon white houses
of the world all right in just a second
we're gonna get to the big social issues
of the day including
the first openly gay active nfl player i
know it's it's
a majestic moment in american history it
matters so so much
because we're gonna do this with every
industry every time so we can continue
to pretend that americans care deeply
about this stuff
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
now would be an excellent time for us to
get involved to stop the left-wing
indoctrination of our children you may
have noticed that sesame street decided
that they are now going to bring out
a gay couple to introduce to three and
four-year-old children it's really
really important that your kids learn
about the variety of sexual orientation
at the age of three and four according
to sesame street
you're not gonna get that from prageru
from prager you you're going to get
traditional american values you're not
going to get critical race theory from
prageru
prageru has launched a massive new k-12
education program
thousands of educators and parents have
already signed up you can check it out
at prageru.com
kids prageru has tons of free kids shows
books magazines with the pro-american
values that aren't being taught in
schools or most kids
shows the prageru website has everything
you need to get your young family
through what's happening in our country
right now
you want your kids to learn about our
nation's founding principles and be
proud of them how about passing on
values you care about like truth freedom
responsibility hard work equality under
god
if you want your kids consuming content
that actually supports your values head
on over to prageru
right now show your children their
animated shows books magazines most
importantly support prageru they're
basically our sister company
they're wonderful 501c3 subscribe now
don't miss prageru's incredible free
kids content visit prageru.com
kids today alrighty in just a second
we'll get to the major social issues of
the day first
there are two books you currently need
on your shelf an old copy of the
dictionary so you can remember what
language was like before the left
decided to completely destroy it and
speechless
controlling words controlling minds by
my friend sort of
michael knowles the book explains how we
got to this point and what it means for
our future lucky for you it is available
everywhere today it really is a good
book which is why i endorse this one
not cynically i endorsed his empty book
last time because it was a joke this
time i actually endorse it's a good book
if you haven't been to the bookstore
lately now would be the time again
speechless is available everywhere today
tuesday june 22nd you can still
pre-order a signed copy of speechless at
premierecollectables.com
speechless before michael's live signing
tonight if you want a copy with his
signature this would be your last chance
that is correct if you've been wanting
dreaming
needing a signed copy of speechless
controlling words controlling minds by
the irrepressible michael moles today is
your last chance to pre-order one before
his virtual live signing tonight 7 30 pm
6 30 pm central
as you know michael's excellent logic
pack book and again i'm not being
sarcastic
it's great it goes deep into the origins
of political correctness why it's so
prevalent in our society today
it's a book you'll wish you'd have
gotten signed if you don't you can
pre-order speechless at
premierecollectables.com
speechless before that signing tonight
that will be streaming at dailywire.com
dailywire youtube and the daily wire
facebook
if you pre-order a copy don't forget to
type a question into the prompter when
you check out then you can tune into his
live signing tonight to see if he
answers your question if he doesn't no
need to worry you still get the copy
with his signature
prepare yourself for an incredibly
interesting and personalized live stream
an excellent new book on your shelf and
finally an ability to understand the pc
police better than they understand
themselves
which is kind of a superpower in today's
day and age one last time
premierecollectables.com
speechless get your signed copy tune in
tonight 7 30 pm eastern 6 30 pm central
at dailywire.com
dailywire youtube dailywear facebook
catch is live signing and maybe even get
one of your burning questions answered
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
all right meanwhile we have massive
social issues shaking america
and an administration committed to
demonstrating
to the world what is best about america
which is of course why tony blinken the
secretary of state has
said that the pride progress flag which
again is
the ugliest flag i mean just on an
aesthetic level
okay forget about what it represents
just on an aesthetic level
it looks like as i've said before a
kaleidoscopic whirlpool of stained glass
crap it is just
ridiculous it is the original rainbow
flag and then
coming in from the side are these weird
arrows pushing the rainbow flag aside
with a variety of colors to represent
transgender
intersex gender non-conforming people
and eventually
it'll just be a giant collage of every
single human in the united states
because of course every single person
has their own sexual orientation
as well as their own gender identity
there is no limit
it is the number is literally infinite
so we should each have our own picture
on the american flag i feel like
at a certain point that that's the
direction we should go we're going to
fly that above the state department
because nothing unifies america
quite like transgender radicalism so
here's tony blinken saying we're going
to fly that
i assume we're not going to be flying
that above the state department and say
yemen
i i just call me call me crazy i just
have a feeling we're not going to be
doing that
we'll be flying the progress flag a
symbol that
encompasses the diversity and
intersectionality of lgbtqi persons
and communities around the world at the
state department uh
later this month we'll fly the flag from
june 26th
to uh the 28th and that's a period that
i know so many knows
uh marks a uh a couple of important
turning points
in uh our history for lgbtqi rights yeah
nothing nothing says unifying america
quite like intersectionality
and flags that represent each individual
orientation on the flag
just wonderful wonderful stuff and by
the way one of the great things about
the intersectional movement is just how
tall and wonderful it is
like let me give you an example so
there's something called the chicago
dyke march
that's what they call it is their name
and a few years ago there was a big
controversy because the chicago dyke
march
banned people from flying any flag that
had a jewish star on it and so people
were like oh that seems anti-semitic and
there's this big controversy and then
they walked it back
well now they're really not making any
bones about where they are at the
chicago dyke march here is the poster
they put out
for the chicago deck march which is to
take place june 26th
okay it is a a woman i assume
uh who is um wearing a bikini
and a thong standing on top of a burning
police car
that says chicago police so you know
it's a burning police car
and on her butt is written a cab
which is the radical slogan all cops are
bastards
and in one hand she's holding a burning
american flag
and in the other hand she's holding a
burning israeli flag so
intersectionality yes nothing is
unifying quite like
intersectional lgbtqia plus
politics it just i mean it really
unifies us all
pretty pretty obviously and by the way
it is not just chicago
according to jason rands who by the way
is a gay man living in seattle he
reports
organizers fear seattle gay pride events
say they are charging white people a
reparations fee to attend
oh goody they have the support of
seattle city council president and
mayoral candidate laurene gonzalez and
the seattle human rights commission
taking black pride okay it's taking back
private they put an l in the middle
because it's clever
organizers say all are welcome to attend
however white allies and accomplices
accomplices must pay the reparations fee
it will be charged on a sliding scale of
10 bucks to 50 bucks depending on one's
ability to pay
the event location is jimi hendrix park
owned by the city of seattle this raises
questions about the legality of a
reparations fee
organizers promote taking black pride as
an event to amplify the voices
narratives and contributions of black
queer and trans voices there will be
live musical performances commentators
art healing spaces prize giveaways at a
coven 19 vaccine clinic according to the
event's listing they say they will focus
on centering who we are and what we need
to feel empowered
joyful and heard so apparently you need
a reparations feel
a fee to feel empowered quote all are
free to attend however
this is a black and brown queer trans
center prioritized valued event
white allies and accomplices are welcome
to attend but will be charged a 10 to 50
reparations fee that will be used to
keep this event free of cost for black
and brown
trans and queer a community um yes
okay meanwhile the big story and it's
leading like all the newspapers
and it is leading over espn and is
leading at huffington post and a drudge
report
the big story of the day is that there
is an active gay nfl player now you may
be asking yourself wait a second wasn't
michael sam drafted by the st louis rams
many years ago
and it was a huge issue at the time
because he kissed his boyfriend at the
time
on national television when he was
drafted and this was considered like a
huge deal
groundbreaking moment because the way
that this works in american politics
is that any time a gay person becomes
the first of anything
in any industry this is a it's a new
groundbreaking moment
that doesn't actually accomplish
progress because that's the way
intersectionality and identity politics
work
because if we were to say you know
michael sam was already in the nfl
at least he was on the practice squad
for the saint louis rams before he ended
up with i think it was like the montreal
alouettes and then fell out of football
before any of that happened i if you
said
well you know life for gay people in
america is pretty good
look at the progress we've made they say
no that's not progress then
there'll be like michael sam's down on
the other oh well that looks like a good
sign of progress nope
not a sign of progress in the same way
that when it comes to race in the united
states
if you're like you know you guys keep
claiming that america's super duper
racist
and it seems kind of like not since we
had a black president for two terms
and when he was elected it was hailed by
the media as a historic moment it's only
a historic moment
if it marks something okay if it marks
nothing it's not a historic moment
but according to the left progress is a
treadmill right it can never be reached
and you never move forward really you're
just kind of walking in place
and the statistics kind of run up we
don't pay attention to those you're
still in the same place so
if you say yeah america doesn't seem so
racist because you know well over 50
percent of the population elected a
rather incompetent president twice
and he was black then everybody
is like no no that's not progress you
don't understand progress
so we play this game every so often
where well first gay person in the nfl
we're like oh my god
unbelievable like wow first gay jockey
incredible you know first gay
impressionist artist who also has one
leg and like oh my god what progress you
meant no
it's not progress that's not progress so
one thing if we hail these sorts of
moves is like oh look how far we've come
isn't that cool
but instead five minutes from now it'll
be like and yes the nfl has more to do
the nfl is still a cruel vicious place
so here is how this is covered
over at espn carl nasib of the uh nasib
i don't know how to pronounce his name
of the las vegas raiders announces he is
gay and pledges a hundred thousand
dollars to the trevor project
nasa 28 made the announcement in an
instagram post said what's up people i'm
at my house here in west chester
pennsylvania i just want to take a quick
moment to say that i'm gay
i've been meaning to do this for a while
now but i finally feel comfortable
enough to get it off my chest
i really have the best life i've got the
best family friends and job a guy could
ask for
i'm a pretty private person so i hope
you guys know i'm really not doing this
for attention
i just think representation and
visibility are so important i actually
hope that like one day videos like this
and the whole coming out process are not
just necessary but until then
i'm gonna do my best and do my part to
cultivate a culture that's accepting
that's compassionate i'm gonna start by
donating a hundred thousand dollars
to the trevor project okay
nice sure right i mean like okay
now has there been any blowback has
anybody been like oh my god that's so
terrible
in 2021 no not one iota of it
but don't worry the left will find
somebody because
again we have to keep making these story
stories even though they really are not
stories
i mean a gay man is the secretary of
transportation and did really well in
the democratic primaries
we've had a gay man as the ambassador to
the united nations rich rick grinnell
under under the
trump administration everybody knows
people who are gay everybody has
business
with people they're gay people working
at every business in the united states
openly
like this is this is really not a thing
but it's going to be turned into a thing
by the media
for purposes of suggesting that america
is really backwards which is always so
weird
because again it's the same thing
they've done with juneteenth juneteenth
is a mark of how far america came in
abolishing slavery and yet it is treated
as a sign of how far america did not
come in doing anything
okay it can't be a historic moment
unless you allow it to be a historic
moment it can't be an important moment
unless you're allowed to be an important
moment so is it important
or is it not you guys are going to have
to decide i'll tell you what is an
important moment in sport
apparently and this is it is a glorious
moment it is truly incredible
an olympics new zealand weightlifter
okay and this weight lifter's name is
laurel hubbard
will become the first transgender
athlete to compete at the olympics now
you got to love
the language here okay because the
reality is
at a normal head that so much of our
media is dedicated
to obscuring actual stories by just
changing the verbiage by just changing
the wording
now the actual headline should be if we
all spoke english together
the actual headline would be biological
male to become first
biological male to compete at the games
in women's weightlifting
right because that's the story if the
story were just
a biological female of any sort of
identity competing against other women
everybody's like okay that's not a story
the reason it's a story is because this
is a dude okay and this dude is a
biological male
hubbard will compete in the super
heavyweight 87 plus kilogram category
her selection made possible by an update
to qualifying requirements in may again
the simple adoption of the pronouns
demanded
changes the nature of the story because
if you just read that sentence you'd be
like i don't understand why this is a
story
right if you if you just read the first
couple of paragraphs
you would not understand what exactly is
going on if you spoke english from like
two years ago
right weight lifter laurel hubbard will
become the first transgender athlete to
compete
at the olympics after being selected by
new zealand for the women's event at the
tokyo games
a decision set to reignite a debate over
inclusion and fairness and sport
hubbard will compete in that category
her selection made possible by an update
to qualifying requirements in may
hey you have to get all the way to the
third paragraph before you understand
what the hell is going on
the 43 year old will be the oldest
lifter at the games had competed in
men's weightlifting competitions before
transitioning in 2013. okay let me just
put it this way to the women that is
wildly unfair this is a dude
who is a full dude in every respect and
continues to be a full dude
just with either some surgeries or some
hormone therapy
but was competing in men's weightlifting
competitions
as of 2013 which means you had the full
bone and muscle development
of a man all the way not just through
puberty but through adulthood
and was competing against dudes in the
same category
and now we're gonna pretend that this is
an even playing field and then it makes
no difference
hubbard said i'm grateful and humbled by
the kindness and support that has been
given to me by so many new zealanders
the new zealand olympics chief karen
smith said it was a historic moment in
sport and for the new zealand team
she is our first olympian who has
transitioned from male to female except
you can't
become a female after being a male that
is not physically possible
we do know that there are many questions
about fairness of transgender athletes
competing in the olympic games but i
would like to take this opportunity to
remind us all that laurel has met all of
the required criteria okay let's just
be fair about this there are no honestly
how many other 43 year old weightlifters
are there
in the olympics i'd love to see a stat
how many 43 year old competitors are
there in actually physically demanding
sports in the olympics you see a lot of
43 year old sprinters in the olympics
seem kind of weird maybe the reason is
because the biology is different here
gang but you're not allowed to say that
hubbard has been eligible to compete at
the olympics since 2015 which the ioc
issued guidelines
allowing any transgender athlete to
compete as a woman provided their
testosterone levels are below 10
nanomoles per liter for at least 12
months before their first competition so
literally
a year and a half after this person was
competing as a male in male weight
lifting competitions
take some estrogen and now you can
compete with the females
truly incredible some tie-in scientists
have said the guidelines do little to
mitigate the biological advantages of
those who have gone through puberty as
males
yeah you think advocates for transgender
inclusion argue the process of
transition decreases that advantage
considerably
and that physical differences between
athletes means there is never truly a
level playing field
um there are broad categories of male
and female in
human biology and all mammalian biology
as it turns out
but you know i'm rooting for hubbard
frankly i think that it's i think it's
great i think hubbard should win
and i think that every male who takes
some estrogen should compete in all the
female categories
and then we can truly have a more truly
diverse and inclusive
society a true meritocracy if you will
hubbard's gold medal wins at the 2019
pacific games in samoa where she topped
the podium ahead of samoa's commonwealth
games champion
fee gaga stowers triggered outrage in
the host nation
samoa's weightlifting boss at hubbard's
selection for tokyo would be like
letting athletes dope
feared it would cost the small pacific
nation a medal yes
belgian weightlifter anna van bellingham
said last month
allowing hubbard to compete was unfair
for women and like a bad joke
that is correct but um
just really really solid stuff there
from the international
olympic committee once again we have
we've created a hell of a society for
ourselves it is truly astonishing to
watch as the new meritocracy
arises okay meanwhile today new york
voting for mayor
so if you're voting for mayor today my
recommendation
my boy andrew yang i like andrew yang uh
i think that
he is the least bad of the available
candidates over there
but i i will never i will never cease
amusement at the fact that every single
new york mayoral candidate
with the exception of one has run
directly screaming away from bill de
blasio and wants more cops
well done liberal governance in new york
city alrighty we'll be back here later
today for additional hour of content be
sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events
all the fundamentals if they matter to
you come check out the show